you
welcome to the exchange in Old Town
Stockholm and as I'm standing here with
mr. horizontal Permanent Secretary of
the Swedish Academy and doors Lessing I
think that choice made a lot of people
happy it made him happy but it also
surprised him a lot I think I think one
of my questions is is she has been on
the list for a long time how come you
show us her this year she's obviously
been discussed for many years I can't
say anything more specific about that
because it's due to the rule of secrecy
but you know sometimes it happens that
writers have to come and go a bit you
know it is in our shortlist and I think
in noiselessness case it was very
significant that we published a sequence
of autobiographical books in the late
1990s in the early years of this century
because they are they are I think is
sort of second peak in her every I think
personally they're some of the most
marvelous books that have been written
about not only about women but also
about Britain about the old Empire about
Western Marxist and and related subjects
so that was an important weight that
contributed to the decision
when you look on her her average say
it's extremely rich and varied she has
written something like 50 books in in 57
years and in very separate stronger stew
well all wrong as I said poetry as far
as I can see and she's good at the mall
you know she's an amazing short story
writer you you tend to identify her with
with large novels 600 pages and and her
greatest masterpiece is admittedly a
rather long book the the four-headed
City but but her short story is also
very good especially there is from
Africa yes and and to the reader who for
some strange reason hasn't read anything
by Doris Lessing where should that
reader begin do you think I suggest that
reader begin with a face book with the
grocer singing which came out in 1950 we
set in South Africa is the sort of
tragedy involving a white farms wife and
her black servants it's a very exciting
one of the most impressive first books
I've ever read but then you must read
the mater quest sequence the children of
violence as is called and particularly I
should say the the last book then you
mustn't miss her autobiography and I
think you I would include in that
judgment the third part which is
formally a novel sweetest dreams yes
but which is really a thinly disguised
biographical story and her latest book
was published as late as this year I
think
oh yes the turfed it's the most amazing
book she goes back to time immemorial
when when they weren't and me humanity
were men and women led a completely
separate life and they weren't really
the same race they were the same species
and she tries to imagine what it was
like when
women started to come together and to
form a united human race and and I mean
it's a wild
kind of
it's like she does sometimes when she
leaves the confines of the realistically
possible and she ventures out into the
visionary the fantastic and into some
wild experiments of thought either in
the future or in in in in in the past or
in a region in space or in in in in
space as it has sometimes been that is
an important part over every it isn't
perhaps the most appreciated because
it's not everybody's cup of tea but but
you shouldn't miss those books now I
think you have watered one of the most
imaginative writers living today so
thank you very much mr. Engel and you
can find more information on the website
www
thank you very much